[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are
indeed very careful boys and today
what's up
we're currently one aren't you off the
wreck i don't know what that means but
we are careful boys so we're careful
today we're going to talk about does
body count matter look
one of my crypto corners recently hit me
up and he's like hey
he's like does it matter if my chick
has had sex with 25 dudes 25 that's it
25 it matters cause she's like almost a
virgin she needs to [ __ ] more way more
that's what i said
how many how many partners has he had i
didn't ask it's probably like he's only
had like one yeah it's usually like that
insecurity factor yeah but that oh and
that's i think that's one of those
things where it's like you have to check
yourself and i think that's what he was
doing i think he's like
hey steve like what do you think of this
and it's like oh dude i think that it
doesn't that doesn't matter and he's
like oh yeah yeah i agree but he was
just wanted like a little bit of an
assurance you know from somewhere so for
me it was like for my um first
girlfriend that was like real and long
term i was like yeah i want i want to be
i want her to be a virgin so i'm a
virgin too and then we [ __ ]
so i was like that was magical
very very [ __ ] inexperiencedly you
know came so fast didn't know what i was
doing oh yeah um
i think even before we [ __ ] she sucked
she sucked me off and i busted in her
mouth and then i had to take a nap
like i couldn't even get to that your
virgin experience would
she really
she shut you off and then you passed out
you're kind of a king dude we used to
well we first started off like
like just fondling each other naked for
like a month that's the best or whatever
and then and then a couple weeks later
like we started doing a lot of oral
and then after that like what's a lot of
worlds like
how much how many milliliters of water
is that probably like every day after
school she's just sucking my dick and
i'm like [ __ ]
and i when i was eating her [ __ ] i was
just [ __ ] licking the curtains all
day i didn't know how to [ __ ] look at
that
after school sex was the best though
yeah i was just [ __ ] pulling those
wings apart and [ __ ] you know like
[ __ ] stretching it out yeah i used to
do that [ __ ] wrong so stupid right
that's how they love it that's just so
stupid all right that's what i do to
this day
finally we're like i think i think she's
ready and then she's like yeah i think
like you know i'm like ready to do the
thing you know i'm not wearing underwear
today and i'm like wow
and then um i actually can i just say i
don't like that the girls don't wear
underwear i like them when a trick is
like yo i want you to know i'm not
wearing underwear yeah i'm like
put some on there
i'm i swear to god disgusting
put it on so i can pick it off you do
exactly that's what it's about i like
that part of it yeah they'll be coming
here naked like have some laundry don't
[ __ ] suppose yeah as a matter of fact
let me take it off go take a shower put
on clothes and then let me tell you put
on a suit of chain man it's like a
present i think it works if if that girl
was wearing a skirt and you had seen her
all day and didn't even think about that
that's a fact she's wearing pants and
she's like i'm not wearing underwear
it's like doesn't make a [ __ ]
difference
she's wearing jeans i'm like oh god damn
are you okay down there like it's gonna
be all [ __ ] raw
and it's the one with buttons as a
zipper
oh so you know it's extra snug and the
honda high-waister
but i do remember being like in high
school and then even in college and
being like i had just so many questions
about
how your exes were like were they
[ __ ] good and better than me i know
they were i [ __ ] know it you're lying
you're a [ __ ] iron [ __ ] stop lying
and then i just start crying and then i
run the other room and i hope they come
and get me
hey bro get out of my head man
get out of my life pretty extreme but i
love it i never did that [ __ ] but that
would be crazy
[Laughter]
i'm a writer you have to put yourself in
other people's heads yeah i did your
empathy but but i would say
a small sprinkle of that everyone in the
beginning i think like you know when
you're [ __ ] finally getting into like
a an adult relationship or [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and then like well i was with an
older girl one time too and i was like
19 she was 23. and then so she hey
baller thank you but she [ __ ] dudes
that are in their late 20s
[Laughter]
and then when you're 19
if her ex-boyfriend was [ __ ] 31 or he
can drive
he could probably [ __ ] buy stocks
he could rent a car i'm like oh my god
he can go to dave and busters by himself
he can't go to chuck e cheese by himself
though [ __ ] way that's like if
imagine if your ex-girlfriend's [ __ ] i
mean your girlfriend's ex-boyfriend was
jason momoa you're like
how do i why me
it's like why
what did you what what do i got that he
don't got you know she said one time he
he wiped his nose on the napkin and
there were some boogies left behind
so there's that but the question is body
count right yeah yeah the bodyguard is
body account it doesn't matter who it is
you it's an unseen number of people like
you don't even know who they are
but the number bothers you yeah i think
it's a number and what it's implying so
like if you're like oh [ __ ] she's so
[ __ ] experienced and then what if i'm
inexperienced then i'm not gonna live up
to whatever and also i think there's
like the societal pressure that dudes
are supposed to [ __ ] lay down but i
can't but i can only lay it down as as
good as what she knows but she's been
with the dude i'm being with a dude
that's had a hundred chicks how do i
compare it's like crypto guys all about
the ratios right
it doesn't matter because she might be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] right she's got like 300
body count but if you're at 314
it doesn't matter
you know what i'm saying it really
doesn't and does body count matter as
much if she's like seven that you're at
one you're [ __ ] insecure like a
i will say this my current wife and i do
say current for a reason to keep her on
her toes
i'm gonna start doing that too thank you
that's fine
i'm gonna adopt you she's she has a more
body count than me right because i was
very like you know percy and [ __ ] like
double well what's that by like double
or triple or just a little bit more
10x
probably times [ __ ] 50
[Laughter]
times 50 easily and you've only been
with 0.2 people deserve it so you're a
bitcoin she's all coins
her ratios are same never going to move
but she's moving all kinds right
in the ratios no no so she's got like
she's got me like
she's got me by
just about a 2x right and so i'm like
you know is that going to [ __ ] with me
some dudes would be insecure with that
yeah yeah yeah but you got a battle dick
steve yeah but it's exactly not good no
but it's really just about your own
personal things like why did she why did
she pick you why is she spending time
with you why she came in with you
so what do you care about that other
[ __ ] it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
actually it's not rational it's
irrational but that's what you know that
can creep right it's a mental creep that
will just happen it will just bleed into
your brain and you start to [ __ ]
think about all the other things they
really satisfy you like you can't really
do it like you and all the [ __ ] but like
that's early stuff thank god that i went
through early like later on you realize
how immature that is and you know
i think it was around my mid-20s or some
[ __ ] but like at that point
i had zero sexual jealousy
like well h you're a maverick dude you
are a maverick he's a man he's a sexual
member you can't speak to the normal
people you're just not knowing about it
so i think what happened though was
when i was insecure because i didn't
[ __ ] that much or like i've only had
like a few partners
or maybe i did [ __ ] but it wasn't like
community like didn't communicate to me
but then after a while i was like i
can't judge
when i myself want to not only did i
like [ __ ] more than 10 at that point i
was like i want to [ __ ] more
so if i want to [ __ ] more
then why am i judging them
for [ __ ] more than me that's that
realization it takes a lot of maturity
to reach though it does because i feel
like especially growing up like suit
like with pseudo-christian values yeah
you're always trying to at least be with
someone that's
lower than you it doesn't matter like so
when you're a virgin you want a virgin
and when you've been with three girls
you want a girl who's been with two guys
like you're always trying to do a little
bit more pure yeah and that's what i
always did i i always gave a big heavy
[ __ ] about it i was really like
particular i'd get mad like if a girl
was like oh like i've been with even if
it was lower than me if i felt like it
was high i'd be like dude that's [ __ ]
gross i started caring more about how
sexually open and liberated they were so
we can have a dope sex fest like you're
[ __ ] their elbow and they're gonna be
weird about it yeah yeah i just [ __ ]
put my dick right here and go
or whatever
or like if they could talk about it
comfortably or like
try different things like techniques
[ __ ] whatever i think it makes it so
much more fun
than having this kind of weird dancing
around of like um you want to [ __ ]
tonight or like being you know like
especially if it's um like girls that
grew up with with a lot of sexual shame
like they always want the guys to pursue
and they never really like initiate and
then also they don't want to talk about
it because it's scary or i don't know
what it is but it happens in a lot of
like asian households too because that's
the main thing i remember like when i
was dating a lot of like asian girls at
the time like it was really difficult to
just
talk about it openly and then i was like
dude like oh no like you're dealing with
a lot and i just want to like connect
and like let's just can we just look at
this as like two adults
trying to express like how they care
about each other sexually or whatever
it's joe pressuring a woman into sex
don't [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
there's also that weird stigma though
right well like uh if a girl is like oh
i've had sex with this many people it's
like you ho
right
it's that whole like thing of how guys
overestimate and girls under count like
it's it's that's there's a value in both
of those
that's why i didn't i didn't come to the
maturity of
thinking that was okay until i dated a
girl like my ex
we finally were like talking about how
many partners we've had and i think at
this time i'd maybe had
maybe like 19
or 20 or something you sex have her i
was like how about you i expected like
my last ted relationship she'd be lower
than me like he always is she goes i
don't know like a hundred something
and i [ __ ] lost my mind dude were you
like like what's that like
losing his mind
no i just like i didn't know how to take
it and i was just like frozen i was like
because at this time we were already
like boyfriend and girlfriend we weren't
like yeah so you can't just like break
the water yeah you can already compete
i was like i would not have [ __ ]
committed to this [ __ ] and i was already
that's what you said or was in your
brain because at the time i was still
under that [ __ ] immature uh no she's
good for you for a minute this is great
yeah and i was just like oh [ __ ] and the
first thing i did after i was like shook
i couldn't even say anything and i got
off the phone with her and then oh you
guys were talking on the phone we were
on the phone yeah and then i how'd you
get off the phone with her do you
remember
wait i just acted like it was nothing
and i was just like oh cool all right
then we just started talking about other
[ __ ] and then i might it was like these
i had tunnel vision i was just like oh
[ __ ] because like up until that point
that was always like a a stupid i don't
know like an unspoken value that you
just have as a guy and the last 10
relationships every time you brought it
up it went in a one direction yeah i was
like 17. oh mine's like four or whatever
and then it was like and i really i was
a [ __ ] dick dude i was like really
mean to her for a while like and that
was the reason and i never like brought
it up and maybe that's why girls don't
want to talk about that [ __ ] nothing 100
100 percent
joe's coming out here i don't think
that's why because that's you know if if
it was me
i would have just been like oh [ __ ] so
you must have sucked the [ __ ] on the
dick like you must be really good at
what you do you're high level show me
truly your skill yeah and then she
doesn't you're like that doesn't feel
like 100 unsatisfied customers
that's like that's more like a 60 or 70
max you open a restaurant that goes out
of business in three years
that's how you get back out that's why i
was talking to myself earlier because
when steve was talking you know like he
was saying like sometimes guys are so
stupid or because people are stupid so
stupid in general because they kind of
get in their own minds right yeah so
like i imagine the dude that's literally
getting a [ __ ] and he goes i bet it
didn't taste like the other guy's dick
because they get in their minds so much
like but she's on your dick right now
why are you like like what the [ __ ] is
wrong she's riding your dick she's
giving herself your dick all this [ __ ]
but you can't handle you like scott
stick way better don't you
you're saying it out loud that's why
you're a [ __ ] bro that's why those guys
are [ __ ] though it takes it takes a
lot and i'm not even hating a [ __ ] if
if you're like that i'm not i'm not even
hating on you you're just being a [ __ ]
but hopefully you can get past this
because we were all this is the phase
it is a phase yeah that's the thing it's
a phase and i wouldn't have been able to
reach that maturity if it wasn't for
being with her because
our relationship became pretty shitty at
that point because of me how i took it
but nothing else was really different
like it didn't herbie 100 guys didn't
have any negative effect besides my own
taste suddenly the next time you look at
your vagina it just like starts to grow
on you for some reason
it's optical i knew something was wrong
before i know it i'm inside looking out
i'm like oh [ __ ]
there's 190 other dudes in there with
you like hey ryan what's going on well
she helped me understand really doesn't
[ __ ] matter but like for a person
like me like i will say i'm a hard
person to convince me but i think that's
way more common amongst guys exactly
like all my friends thought exactly like
i did no one's like joe no that's very
rare
what are you talking about i agree i
thought like that no you did it dude no
you did no you did it okay i did until i
was mid-20s joe's insecurity is sad but
it's okay
huh i always mean 20s at this right and
then you kind of like grow out of it
because i mean that that was why i was
like my first has to be a virgin because
it just felt weird and wrong and you
were right someone just honestly like it
just helps to be checked as a guy like
it helps for some girl to just come in
your life and just [ __ ] check your
values but you also see the benefit of
dating someone with a lot of experience
because then you don't have to deal with
all of the [ __ ] and like their
insecurities just like how guys have
insecurities
when they're inexperienced like girls do
too right and then so like you have two
[ __ ] insecure kids like that don't
know how to [ __ ] actually
be an adult yet like i think that's a
big part of it but writ large the best
things that have broken me through like
anytime everyone always talks about
wondering breakthroughs right but you
have to come across something really
difficult to break through it that's
true every time that's ever happened to
me it was somebody just being like yo
steve you know why you suck at this
because of this
and like every time it's like you either
just cry like a [ __ ] and you're gonna
cry at first you're gonna be like this
sucks man [ __ ] i can't believe i suck at
this right but if you if you want to
push through that you have to just man
up and be like okay yeah i okay i want
to get better at this so so what's the
next step so is there a pivotal moment
where you guys remember because i don't
remember mine well yeah but it wasn't
sexual for me it was comedy wise like it
was like doing improv it was like my
improv guru guy i love his name's
trenton shine he uh he told me he's like
hey steve you you want to know why you
suck at improv and then he was like you
make it all about you you're making it
all about you it's me pro you're me
providing which you guys know i'm big on
[ __ ] i hate knee providing like like
i always talk about
what's an example oh just like somebody
who's going to um
make the scene still focus and make the
scene about them instead of trying to uh
do the magic trick of like incorporating
everyone into the scene right so like
hey i've noticed somebody's being quiet
how do i bring them into the scene hey
i've noticed somebody isn't doesn't feel
comfortable to jump in the scene how do
i get them in the scene that's the most
important thing if you can make your
partner look good that's how you look
good if you look like a ballpark partner
you suck an improv so i didn't really
realize that when you do like the whole
like oh it's all steve dance like that's
you still improvising
no no i'm not i'm not i'm not me
surprising i'm actually bringing you in
is that right yeah i'm making you look
good i feel like i do a good job making
you look good well he's setting you up
for a comeback because you're so good at
those is that right you are really good
at not me provisioning
[Laughter]
that was an example right there yeah
i'll set you up for that because i was
so so that changed your whole entire
world view of not thinking so selfishly
yeah and then so that reflected in sex
getting a laugh if you're getting a
laugh then it's like that's all that
matters but that's not all that matters
the team is what matters making making
everyone on the team look good man
right it's about the room but but so
like sexually even it was it was about
like foregoing your own personal ego
[ __ ]
and like for me particularly um
not treating every woman as a copy paste
right so it's like you have had sex with
whoever however many people but you
think that you know how to work a [ __ ]
like that's what i was saying you don't
bro you're [ __ ] you
but that's it right this just needs more
coal
this [ __ ] is working real good
that's that's the whole thing right it's
like it's like thinking that industrial
revolution because you made your first
girlfriend come one way yeah now you're
with your [ __ ] ninth or whatever
you're like how come it's not working
but you're not listening to them you're
not taking like their particular like
like situation into account how they're
more mental or whatever you just don't
pay attention to that [ __ ] you just sort
of like i'm gonna hammer that [ __ ]
[ __ ] hard
i'm coming for you you're right though
you're right [ __ ] oh
i know you like that [ __ ]
cause guys are [ __ ] stupid as [ __ ]
you know what i mean i realized too that
body count is nowhere near as important
as like
i think it's a bigger problem if someone
that you've had in the past is still
lingering and is creating problems for
your current relationship and that's
only one person yeah because like
my ex had been 100 guys i never saw any
of them but if i was with like 10 girls
and one of them kept [ __ ] bugging us
that's a bigger problem that is a big
quantity right
true that's true plus there's also
there's also the quantity in general of
like body count right it's like uh
[ __ ] you're you're with 10 people
one time or with one person 100 times
that's true
that's what i started thinking like in
like later on in my 20s when i was like
well what if this person [ __ ] 20
people one time and this person was in
like a a five-year relationship with
like one person but they [ __ ]
thousands of times who had more
experience 365 days a year that's
literally what i just said i just saw a
different ratio
i thought about this too inflated
numbers i thought about this too i was
like what if like you're with one person
for like 10 years and you guys are
[ __ ] like 10 000 times yeah yeah yeah
yeah versus like you're like somebody's
like [ __ ] 10 000 ratios ratios
it's really interesting you said that
what i was trying to add to that point
is
their experience level and quality of
sex is probably going to be much better
versus someone who's just only had a
bunch of one-night stands
ah
that's actually what i learned um in me
and gio's relationship both of us
actually have really low counts i think
both of us are under five each thank god
glory to the lord
i'm the [ __ ] fans
this guy's going to heaven i got the i
got the [ __ ] logo yeah both of us
[ __ ] pearly gates are under five each
but since we've been together for so
long we've been different people in our
relationship so i i think even then like
we've kind of it almost feels like we've
had three or four relationships in the
same one
and i think the thing that we learned
the most is like in the beginning
through all the fights or just all the
turmoil you kind of work out
all these bad things that maybe you you
had trauma from before or problems you
didn't work out before
and as you
uh grow together you start to realize
what are the good things that you focus
on
rather than the bad things or the things
that could be
so i think like now let's say if we were
to like unfortunately break up or
something like that like body count
wouldn't matter to me at all because now
i understand what it really means to be
in a relationship or to like have sex or
to be intimate like all of it is all
about the quality and the connection
versus everything else that you thought
it was that's so true i thought you were
gonna say like you learned ball licking
was like your thing yeah but then not so
much hand jobs like but then you know
maybe a little bit above play but not
all the time and then like you start to
weed out the things you like but that's
also true though
you know what i loved about what bartra
said
if it was anybody else given that same
speech part would have stood up
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]